one more major focus of the president's
trip to Japan is how to counter China's
huge military buildup in the Pacific
Japan is already committed to doubling
its defense budget a historic departure
from long-time policies introduced after
the pain of World War II Elizabeth
farmer has more from Hiroshima Liz good
morning
good morning Japan is America's biggest
Ally in the Pacific and it has as you
said already started to reinvent its
military to cope with the new security
challenges in this region
military wants to transform itself into
a formidable fighting force but to get
there it will have to overhaul its
pacifist self-image Japan's Constitution
was written by American occupation
authorities after World War II and it's
set out to make sure the country never
went to war again so it actually bans
Japan from settling international
disputes by force
but China's aggression has changed
everything
last August it fired five missiles that
landed in Japanese Waters and in
December China sailed its aircraft
carrier between two of Japan's Southern
Islands
as a result there's broad support these
days for a more muscular military
is a professor of defense policy in
Tokyo it could have been much more
controversial had it not been for uh
China's massive military buildup it's
coercive and sometimes even aggressive
actions that it's taking in the South
China Sea Japan hosted a defense and
security show this spring which
attracted manufacturers of every kind of
military equipment from reconnaissance
robots to aircraft they all have their
eye on Japan's plans to double its
defense spending by 2027 which will give
it the third highest defense budget in
the world
billions will flow to U.S companies for
weapons like tomahawk missiles and F-35
fighter planes but all this represents a
huge cultural shift until now the
Defense Forces that's the military's
official name have been better known for
search and rescue Services than combat
even the latest action-packed recruiting
videos aren't convincing young Japanese
to enlist in droves in fact the most
recent drive to sign up ten thousand new
service members missed the Target by
half
now here at the G7 the war in Ukraine
and Vladimir Putin's recent moves to
reposition his nuclear tactical nuclear
weapons are going to be top of the
agenda and of course it has special
poignancy because Hiroshima where we are
is where the U.S dropped the very first
atomic bomb back in 1945 at the end of
the second world war Gail
all right a good reminder on that thank
you Elizabeth Palmer reporting from
Japan